it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen go ahead it's simple and it's
easy or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
expert Elizabeth Warner joins us right
now what's going on I'm so excited to
see you thank you for having me all
right so tell me about my phone are you
ready for the Epic summer party this is
it these are from Big Mouth these are
actually inflatable sprinklers so think
of the old rusty sprinkler that we had
that we used to jump over when we were
little well these when you get them home
you inflate them with a pump maybe the
pump that used to blow up an air
mattress or whatever or your your soccer
balls you blow them up then you simply
attach a garden hose and then the magic
begins now we just set these up at home
for a group of kids in our neighborhood
and the magic was undeniable they all
came it was like this is it look at this
so all of the kids came over we have a
bunch of them on cbsdeals.com so we've
got a cupcake we've got a huge fire
hydrant they just sprinkle from all over
the place of them spin on top some of
them spin on the top the Unicorn it
comes out of that horn you can see with
the fire hydrant and the cupcake they
spin on the top water on the sides all
amazing this is what's going to make
summer great for everyone that's how you
make the neighbors jealous yes and these
start at just
49.99 they're up to 29 off must-have for
the summer okay let's talk about clean
air for a minute okay this is the clean
light air and Air Pro now these are air
filters that are going to get all those
little particles floating in the air
that are pollutants and they're going to
take them away so when we breathe we
breathe easier and cleaner last week
with all the fires in Maryland it was
really bad and what I didn't realize was
that it was really bad indoors in my
home we woke up I had a headache look at
that 112 that's what it read on red it
was dangerous levels in my home I didn't
even see the smoke turn these on in all
the room rooms and look it went down to
four and it was great so these these
will help absorb that smoke but also
odors I'm cutting onions you can see
It'll take that away the kids in the car
this will fit right into a cup holder
you can take these on the go so if
you're on an airplane you want to maybe
have that air fresh around you they're
tiny quiet road trips everywhere you go
by your desk at work in the kitchen in
the bathroom they will travel with you
so these start at just
69.99 they are up to 58 off those are
Necessities yes okay so this is
something that can help keep you cool
yeah so temperatures go up yes so
Mission they bring us Serena Williams so
we know when it's hot out she's working
hard she's sweating she wants to cool
down so she has an entire line of
products I'm going to hand you this one
this looks like a mug to put coffee in
it's actually a fan so this is going to
cool you off inside there's an ice pack
that I've already previously frozen okay
place it inside four double a batteries
on the top or you can plug it in so you
can have it by your bed you push that
fan on and unlike a regular fan that
just blows warm air or whatever airs
around you this is cold yeah for my
personal summer is amazing now uh also
for everybody in the summertime so this
is the other product and you're getting
both of these today this is an actual
towel we wet it ring it snap it and then
we just wrap it around our neck I don't
want I don't know if you don't if you
don't go ahead
oh yes so it brings down the body
temperature 30 days I run high so think
of running exercising mowing the yard
golfing you name it you can put this on
and it's going to bring that body
temperature down so these are 27.50 for
a set of two you're getting that and the
towel so keeping you I'm not gonna lie
you had me at Serena yes Serena what
about that right there so check this out
this is amazing it's already 5 following
you okay I'm gonna switch the camera
around and if you don't mind just stand
right there for a second I'm going to
hit that now I want you to walk around a
little bit this is kivo and yeah go
ahead go ahead so with people you're
going to be able to turn your phone into
an actual camera person it does all the
work for you it's got AI built in so
it's going to be able to follow you it
tracks you does your videos your photos
if you want to live stream do a zoom
meeting with a presentation or if you're
just somebody like our kids doing the
content they're doing their dancing
they're having fun they're going to be
able to record all of that and this one
89.99 it is 40 off this is my favorite
Gadget I've taken that ever yes this is
amazing for the whole family yeah for
everybody the kids are going to try and
take Elizabeth you're the best we
appreciate you of course we partner with
all these companies to get these deals
to buy anything that you saw today scan
the QR code on your screen or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping now